Unknown unknowns.
Well, unknown unknowns come to you from places you don't expect.
Because other you had prepared for that damn thing.
So, these are the things that always open their mouths when you don't expect it.
They are just like, say, snakes in the garden of Eden, that might be a way to think about it.
You can't keep the damned snakes out of the garden.
And that's because you can't make limits to keep complexity out of it.
The complexity always returns secretly. Try to defend your children from the internet,
For instance.
You cannot make limits to keep the complexity out of it, it always comes back secretly.
So what would an unknown unfamiliarity be? That's a good one. Here,
You have an intimate relationship. You have this for 10 years. You trust your partner.
So what does that mean?
You know where you are. You know who you are. And you also have a reasonable idea of ​​where you are going.
And then one day you find out that your partner cheated, not with one person but with three.
During the entire 10 years!
Well, hypothetically, that comes as a shock. But you may have missed many indications that indicated this.
Non relevant!
Let's say it comes as a shock, what happens to you?
You don't know where you are.
You do not know where you have been! That is interesting!
Because you think you know where you are because you have already been there.
But suddenly something happens and you are so upset that you don't even know where you were.
So in a way that means that the past depends on the now. A very strange thing.
You also have no idea where you are going.
Regarding 'not knowing where you are going', that is very deep.
You may think "I thought I was in a marriage", that's wrong,
"I thought I knew who my wife / husband was", that's wrong too.
"Because I thought I knew my wife, I thought I knew women in general", that's wrong.
"I thought I was in a relationship with someone I could trust," that's wrong.
"I don't know enough about trust, I'm clearly too gullible."
And because that all happens, I doubt everything that ever happened to me, yes?
That is the emergence of chaos!
And that is..
This! Sometimes you go from point A to point B and something you don't expect will manifest itself in the middle of your plan.
But it's not such a disaster, because you can just ignore it.
And sometimes something appears and oh, then you just don't have a plan anymore.
And then you ask yourself, where exactly are you when you don't know where you are?
I'd say that's a place! And it is actually a place that is very well documented in classical and religious mythological stories.
That is chaos.
For example, the Daoists believe that the world is made of chaos and order.
Order, that's where you are when what you do gives you back what you want.
Chaos.
That is where you are when you have no idea what is happening.
And then you can ask, is there a way you should behave when you are in chaos?
The answer to that is: there is a way better.
Because it is a place that you will visit several times in your life. And everyone visits this place.
That is why it is an archetypal story, it is the descent to the underworld.
The underworld is that terrible place that lies under all our assumptions.
It is .. Cold lake that lurks under the thin ice that everyone skates on.
And it is something that can manifest itself at any time.
That is probably why, in the Daoist symbol, the black paisley is chaos and the white is order,
In the Order paisley is a little black dot, that is because order can turn into chaos, what it does at any time.
And the reverse is also true. Chaos can change in order at any time.
And insight will do that for you. And alcoholics say that when they reach their low point,
then it is so * click * there is a catalysis and they look at the world in a different way.
Now they are a new person, they are back from the underworld, returned from death, so to speak.
And this is partly because your right hemisphere seems to be good at this,
derive patterns in chaotic places. It keeps track of what abnormal things are happening.
And it makes alternative maps of the world that are there for you to use.
At least to a certain point, if ever necessary.